for the morning session on Wednesday so
until now we have seen mainly three
themes so we have discussed how to do
sequential hypothesis testing and we saw
how you can do that adaptively and in
cases where non-adaptive techniques also
work well we had in that team we had the
Talks by Annie by uh Chan and by Kira
and then yesterday we discussed about
inference through the Talks by Vivek and
Panos and Ilan and also the Talks by
Hana and Anis in the previous day and
also Steve talked also about interest
but also including strategic component
the statistic component and incentives
we're going to see more about incentives
tomorrow
yesterday afternoon we talked about the
uh the situations where the input is
mostly IID but you're going to build a
bus to cases where you have some
adversarial components some worst case
components so we had the Talks by Hala
by Julian and uh by Victor in that line
of work so what we're going to do in
this session is that we're going to move
towards the worst case extreme and we're
going to try to uh to think about worst
case approaches now a class a typical
drawback of worst case approaches is
that they tend to be very pessimistic so
in the theme of the information works
that we're having we're going to discuss
what information can you have about your
your the future in order to to be able
to
achieve enhanced performance in your
system so not refer to the worst case so
this is generally the theme of learning
augmented algorithms and this will be
the area the subject of this first
session so we are going to try to
understand what information can we add
to classical gorgeous approaches in
order to improve the performance when
this information is accurate gracefully
degrade with the performance when it's
not and I still retain the worst case
guarantees while also we're going to
also discuss learnability and how we can
learn so our first speaker will be
yourself who's doing this eventually
you'll see is a professor at Tel Aviv
university has done phenomenal work on
online algorithms scheduling and
multiple other aspects on the online
decision making Brands theoretical
computer science and uh without further
Ado just take it away
okay thank you so first of all I would
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me I was supposed to be there
in person but unfortunately I had to
cancel the trip last week but I'll still
give the talk by Zoo so I'm going to
talk about a very basic and simple
problem of flow time also called the
response time uh with uncertain
processing times on a single machine and
this is a joint work with Stefano Laura
the Leonardi from Rome and Norm twitto
which was my graduate students uh from
Tel Aviv when he graduated a couple of
months ago and started a move to Amazon
and that actually the also the slides
were prepared by my students
so the problem is we are start
immediately without any uh directly with
the problem I'm talking about jobs which
are released over time on a single
machine and each job queue takes
processing time certain processing time
called the apq
and in the online scheduling problem the
jobs are revealed upon the release time
so only when you uh the job is released
you get to know is uh its processing
time and you really know that that these
jobs exists and the algorithm has to do
only some very simple tasks to decide
which job to process at any point of
time
and now we move to the goal function the
goal function is to minimize the total
flow time also called total response
time which is precisely the sum overall
jobs of the difference between the
completion time and the release time of
the job it's actually the amount of time
that the job has been in the system and
you just sum it up over uh our job and
this is actually the total flow time
which is equivalent to average flow time
average response time all these things
are the same
and let me just take a simple example
let's say that this is the time line at
Time Zero you have two jobs the blue one
whose processing time is two and the red
one is processing time is five and let's
say that I decide to process the red job
until time four time four a green job is
released whose processing time is two
and I decided to switch to the green job
so uh I haven't mentioned yet but you
are allowed to do a preemptions
preemptions stop a job start a different
job and then return back to a previous
job so let's say that we process the
green job for two minutes of time and we
completed it and then we return to the
red job and completes it and then to the
blue job
so uh if we now compute the response
time or the flow time of each job so if
the green job is is great it has two is
the minimum possible response time but
the the red one is seven and the blue
one is nine and then we just sum it up
and get 18. so this is a very simple and
basic problem and it's uh what's nice
about it that it actually has an optimal
online algorithm
so this is in and the algorithm is just
to process called srpt at any point of
time we process the job with the
shortest remaining processing time
this is an example of a very uh rare
situation in online algorithm that you
actually get one competitive algorithm
which is actually equal to the optimum
solution although you're in an online uh
scenario
uh MBR routing is very simple just
process the shortest remaining uh the
job with the shortest remaining
processing time
um a
um the thing is that you need to know
the exact processing time of the job
upon its release
and this is how this is hardly happens
in the sense that uh you typically know
the size approximately the size of the
job you're not sure exactly about the
exact forces in time so instead of uh so
this is like one extreme where you know
the exact processing time so if you are
not sure about the processing time you
can look at the completely ever extreme
where which is called non-carvoyant
setting uh in this case uh the job sizes
are not known in advance actually there
are you only once you finish the job
you know it's processing time so this is
like the completely over extreme where
you uh don't have any information about
processing time and then
um here the situation is much it's not
as nice and instead of one competitive
you have actually uh competitive ratio
which depends on the size of the input
it's not a fixed competitor it's not
even two or ten it depends on the size
of the input and then of course there is
a difference between deterministic and
random random randomized algorithms but
it's not constant in in any way
um but this is completely The Other
Extreme so now the typical case that we
can think of is that you actually you
have an estimate of the processing time
of the job you know the re the
approximately how much it will run but
not precisely then we look at the
following scenario when you get a new
job again jobs are released over time
and only when job is released you you
get to know that it exists so you get an
estimate PQ tilde instead of PQ
a PQ is a real processing time but you
get a message how you would get such an
estimate first of all you can get it
from the user the user knows what type
of job is sent to the system so we can
give its estimate
a alternative you can get you can do it
by heuristics you can analyze sometimes
the algorithm you can see how many loops
and what's their structure and get an
estimate on the processing time and even
more in a more sophisticated way you can
use a machine learning prediction where
you
um you consider many attributes of the
program and decide and provide a
prediction on the processing tab
and the idea that uh okay so now we
don't know precisely the processing time
so we cannot be one competitive which
means we cannot achieve the optimal
solution but we want to get an online
algorithm with competitive ratio uh
depends on the um on the accuracy of the
estimates
um by the way I don't have on the slides
of definition of competitive ratio I
assume that every everyone knows it but
let me just mention it for completeness
competitive ratio of the algorithm is
the ratio between the processing the the
performance of the online algorithm
compared to the optimum offline
algorithm that knows the whole sequence
the all input or the whole sequence of
input in advance
so you compare the performance of the
algorithm uh the online algorithm is the
optimal solution that they have all the
information in advance so we want it to
depend on the accus accuracy of the
estimates uh of the prediction of the
processing time of course if the
estimates are excellent you want it to
be small but if the estimates are really
far away from the truth then there is no
way I mean you assume that the
competitive restroom is not is not it's
not going to be so so nice or so good
so uh now the question is how to measure
the accuracy of the estimates that you
are provided with
so there are two types of Errors either
your estimates are larger or smaller
from uh from the real size of the job so
you might have an underestimation factor
which means that the job is really
longer with what you estimated and the
maximum ratio is called new one so these
jobs are really larger than what you
estimated and there is a overestimation
factor which is of course the maximum
ratio of of the estimation divided by
the real side of the job so
overestimation the rear size is smaller
than the estimation and you look at the
maximum ratio
note that these two types of errors or
estimations are really different in the
sense that during the algorithm you can
for example you can process a job and
then figure out that is that its
processing time is low is longer when
you what you expected
um and then realize that you are in the
underestimate that you are in the
underestimation that underestimation uh
regime while overestimation is a bit
harder because you are given many jobs
and some of them could be very short but
there is no way to find which jobs are
really shorter unless you process all of
them in some sense so these two types of
errors are not completely symmetric but
still we view him in a symmetric
symmetric fashion and we Define the
Distortion as the product of um
of these two factors mu 1 and mu 2. uh
please note that somehow if all
estimations are actually twice let's say
twice the real size of the job then the
uh the new one is actually two
uh mu2 you can think about it as one but
actually you can think about it as also
half and then the way that we view it is
the Distortion is only one
because it's two times half so in some
sense we want to claim that if all
estimations are let's say twice
precisely twice the size of the real job
we really want to get an algorithm which
is very excellent in the sense which is
very close to one competitive because
the Distortion is very small is only one
in that case so it's a nice nice
property of this definition but
typically both mu1 and mu2 are going to
be larger than one
okay so um now the question now the next
question is do we know the Distortion in
advance or we only realize it why we
process the the jobs during the
algorithm
so
um so okay so in general we want to get
as I mentioned in algorithm whose
competitive ratio is a function only of
the distortion
and the uh interesting thing is we can
like one natural algorithm to use is
shorter shortest remaining estimated
processing time instead of shortest
remaining processing time because we
have the estimation instead of the real
size of the job unfortunately this
algorithm is not only not that it's it's
not only not one competitive it's
actually in some sense infinite
competitive it depends on the ratio
between the size of the jobs and it's
really very surprisingly a very bad
algorithm and I'll give you a show
intuition why this happens if you
started the if you process a job and
actually you finish it so the estimation
the shortest remaining uh estimation
posting time is zero so this job would
get highest priority although it might
be still long time is left and you would
process this job instead of instead of
processing strong jobs and that cause
very high competitive ratio and so it
turns out that like the natural
algorithm is not competitive at all when
you have a distortion
um so as I mentioned I want to this I
want to look at two cases one is that
the Distortion is known in advance and
the other that it is not now so if it is
normally in advance I call it robust
algorithm this is a non-standard name
okay robust is used for different
algorithms but not specifically in this
area and here
for every parameter view which is the
known Distortion I want to get an
algorithm I'll give you which depends on
the known Distortion and its competitive
ratio is f of mu
uh so here I have a family of algorithms
or an algorithm with a parameter
and the competitive ratio depends on the
on the Distortion a much stronger notion
it's what's called Distortion oblivious
algorithm here we assume that we don't
know the Distortion in advance and here
we have a single algorithm
uh called ARG that for every Distortion
mu the algorithm is f of VO competitive
on input with Distortion view so please
note that I'm looking at as was
mentioned in the beginning on the worst
case input I want that my algorithm will
work and achieve the performance for
every possible input and for every
possible error in that sense
so obviously the second notion is what
we prefer and it's a much better
algorithm
uh obviously Distortion oblivious
implies
um you're robust but not vice versa so
this is what we want to achieve and the
uh our result from soda 22 is as follows
we present a distortion oblivious
algorithm deterministic algorithm which
is mirror mu competitive for every
possible input and forever possible
Distortion and this is the first
Distortion I believe it's algorithm for
this problem
and we also show nearly matching lower
bound which is Omegle free so you cannot
get you cannot hope to get something
which is sub-linear depending on mu and
for every even for randomized Darwin so
let me just explain what it is so let's
say that you are uh you you have an
estimate which are one plus Epsilon
compared to the real size or twice
compared to the ridge size in that case
you get a constant competitive algorithm
so obviously you wouldn't get one
competitive algorithm but you will get
constant competitive algorithm small
constant while running shortest
remaining estimated processing time
might get you infinite competitive
algorithm
uh so this is the result and now I'm
going to switch to a more General
General problem which is called weighted
flow time which is actually exactly the
same as flow time but each job has some
importance which is called weight and
now the goal function instead of being
just the time in the system completion
time minus release time which is the
time in which the job is in the system I
multiplied by the importance so there
are more important jobs and they are
weighted with a larger weight and the
goal is actually to minimize the
weighted uh flow time or weighted
response time
uh okay so let's take the again an
example that we already used before so
here we have again two jobs one the
processing time is written inside the
rectangle and the way it is written
above the rectangle so the blue job is
forcing time two and a way to the red
job is longer
is five but it's that is higher
importance six and let's say so I decide
to run the red job until time four and
then I get a um a green job
which is very short uh but and and also
as high importance so job which are
short and have high importance would
have higher priority in some sense
because
like shortest remaining processing time
prefer shorter jobs and here if they
have a higher priority it would even
prefer them more so I'm going to switch
to the green job and the Finish finish
it and then switch to the red job and to
and then finish the Bluetooth so again
if we look it's the same as in the
previous example the green job as a
processing time or uh sorry um a flow
time or response time too and the red
one is seven and the blue one is nine
but now we multiply by its importance
so the 7 is multiplied by 6 and the
awesome and the R2 is multiplied by 8
and the 9 is multiplied by two and then
we get 76. so this is uh just the
weighted response time or weighted flow
time now surprisingly this problem is
much more complicated than the
unweighted version and now even on a
single machine even when we know that
precisely the uh processing time of a
job upon arrival again we are in the
online a problem still we cannot get
constant competitive algorithm
specifically the competitive ratio would
differ would depend on the uh P either P
or W where p is the ratio between the
largest job to the smallest one and W is
the ratio between the maximum weight to
the minimum weight
again weight is important it's the
importance and the already in stock 2001
uhuricana and Zoo proved the log Square
P competitive algorithm then in Cuban
cylinder and they're proved in so the
2003 log W competitive algorithm and
actually a few years ago we uh with Norm
for a student we improved the log Square
P to log p
so here again
um this is assuming that we know the
exact choice of a job upon its release
time it's still an online problem but we
know the processing time upon release
time
here we generalize it to the case that
there is a distortion that there is an
error that we have only estimation
uh so here if mu is the uh Distortion we
get mu Square log W again W is the is
the weight the ratio between the maximum
weight to the minimum weight or mu Cube
uh Times log mu P repeats the ratio
between this largest job to the minimum
job but unfortunately now we are don't
have a distortion or believe this
algorithm we just have a mural bust
which means that we need to know the
processing time sorry the Distortion in
advance we need to know an upper bound
on the Distortion and the competitive
direction would depend on this upper
bound
spoiler for the end this is an open
problem how to get a distortion
oblivious algorithm for the weighted
flow time on a single machine
we don't know how to achieve it
again we cannot hope to get much better
bound at least for constant Distortion
Like a natural natural scenario as the
Distortion is small one plus Epsilon one
and a half or two and then we uh when we
in our algorithm matches uh the um the
previous
um competitive ratio for the case that
we know the size the processing time of
each job precisely upon its release time
okay so uh let me summarize the results
that we that we have so we have two
cases one is a mural bust where we know
the error in advance or an upper bound
of the error events a versus Distortion
oblivious where we don't know the errors
in advance
if we uh for Distortion oblivious which
is a much nicer notion we only know how
to deal with the unweighted case and we
provide an algorithm which is mule log
mu competitive
a while for the way for the weighted
case we need to know the Distortion in
advance and we get
also worse bound because it's a weighted
case it's more complicated case we get a
mu Square competitive algorithm
uh now uh a natural question would be
can we remove somehow in a black box
fashion uh the Assumption between no um
you in advance
actually this is like can we like in a
black black box fashion get them your
bust algorithm and create a distortion
oblivious algorithm
so like a natural way to do it would be
the following let's guess the distortion
so let's guess the Distortion and
pretend that we know the distortion
this is this is something which is uh
typically used in online algorithm which
is called doubling you guess and if your
guess is incorrect you fix it
the problem is that we have two types of
possible errors obviously if there are
guests who have overshooting our guests
or under
let's say that our guess was much larger
okay the Distortion was two but we
guessed one thousand so the competitive
ratio would depend on 1000 and not on
two so we actually get Omega of the our
guess and not of the real distortion so
let's be more so this is One Direction
so let's be more uh conservative and try
to
um I guess a smaller number
unfortunately if we get if we guess a
number which is four times smaller than
the real Distortion then our algorithm
complex then our algorithm specifically
completely uh fails and provide a
unbounded competitive ratio it may get
unbounded competitive ratio so we don't
know how to take a robust algorithm and
create a distortion oblivious algorithm
now I'm going to discuss uh just to to
just to discuss the error measure
so our our measure is the maximum
Distortion so we look at the job whose
Distortion is the largest compared to
its real size and and our algorithm
depends on this number and the question
is why not to
why not to have an algorithm whose error
depends on the L1 distance the sum of
the distribution instead of the maximum
distortion so the reason is that we want
to make our error as small as possible
and then our algorithm will be as best
would be much better so if we Define the
error to be smaller then the performance
algorithm of the algorithm is better so
we prefer and since the maximum
Distortion is always smaller than the L1
distance the sum of the distortions it's
better to have an algorithm whose
competitive Direction depends on the
maximum Distortion versus an algorithm
is competitive ratio depends on the L1
the sum of the distortions so now you
should obviously ask me why so why
you're not to use average Distortion
average distortion which means we look
at each job we look at what is
Distortion is
size compared to the estimates versus
its screen size the ratio and we look at
the average Distortion this would be
certainly better than the maximum
Distortion so here we get a smaller
number and if we are able to get an
algorithm this competitive ratio will
depend on the average Distortion instead
of the maximum Distortion then our
algorithm would be even better
unfortunately we can design an example
where only constant number of jobs have
a high disclosure and then we have
infinite or very large number of jobs
whose Distortion is one actually they
don't have any Distortion so if we look
at the average the average in the limit
approaches one the Distortion of average
Distortion because we have only constant
number of jobs with high Distortion all
the rest are one and but we can
provide uh but we can provide the lower
bound that that in this case the
Distortion will be will still be equal
unfortunately to the maximum distortion
so there is no way
to uh get an algorithm uh whose
competitive ratio would depend on the
average resource Distortion versus the
maximum Distortion so even if we have
very few jobs which have the wrong
estimates we can get into a trouble and
even if all the remaining jobs forever
will be correct we might have of course
in the worst case I'm not saying that
always in the worst case and of course
in very contrived input we can have a
competitive ratio which is large
although or almost all jobs are correct
okay so this is this so this was the uh
introduction and um
um and now in the remaining time I'm
going to describe the algorithm so again
I need to describe for you two
algorithms one for the unweighted case
and with unknown Distortion and the
other is for the weighted case with
known Distortion so first of all I'm
going to describe the intersection of
the two the easiest algorithm which is
unweighted case but with long Distortion
so this is easier than the two uh um
results that I mentioned unweighted
cases all the job have the same inter
importance I just want to minimize the
sum of the flow time of the sum of the
uh response time uh and um we know
maximum amount that is the maximum a
bound of the maximum distortion so here
is the algorithm to define the algorithm
we use just visualization of the jobs
job is will be visualized as a rectangle
its height going to be one in general
it's going to be its weight but since we
are now in the unweighted case our job
if the same importance the height of the
rectangle will always be one and the a
width is going to be its processing time
and the processing time
is always shrinking because once we
process the job the processing time the
remaining processing time becoming
smaller and smaller so the rectangle
will be shrimped in its width
so each job is described as a rectangle
um and obviously the width is the
processing time as well as the area
now
the unweighted algorithm with known
Distortion is as follows we have two
types of beans
the one of them is called f it's the
full jobs and the other is a bin for a
partial juice so here there are jobs
which haven't been processed yet at all
and here the jobs already started to be
processed for the so the width has been
might have been slightly shrinked
and now incoming jobs when we get a new
job which is released over time we
always put it in the full bin and later
I will describe how to put it in the
form in the full beam and processing is
done only through uh the partial beam
only jobs in the partial bins are going
to be processed and obviously at some
point of time we need to move jobs from
before being to the partial beam and the
way to do it is when the number of jobs
in general the weight of the jobs now
the weight is equal one if the number of
jobs here is larger than the number of
jobs here so we move one job from here
to one job from here and I'll describe
it immediately how to do it so let's do
one step at a time so first of all let's
look uh what um what happens when job is
released again we have when job is
released it's going to enter only the
full being
so uh we have a job queue these are the
estimates note that we know only the
estimates we don't know the real
processing time of the job the real
processing time might be different than
the estimates for example two jobs one
job might have a higher estimate from
another job a might have an higher
estimate compared to Joby but job B
might have a longer processing time
compared to Jobe because we have
estimates and we don't have the real
processing time
so when we get a new job queue we put it
we want to put it at the top
okay uh the thing is that we want to
have a preference to Shorter jobs
shorted in and want to put the shorter
jobs over on the top but we are not sure
about the real processing time so we are
going to identify jobs whose processing
time is certainly shorter than the new
job which has been added so let's say
that we have here free such jobs q1 Q2
and Q3 how do we know that the
processing time is shorter certainly
shorter than Q because the estimate as a
factor of at least mu If the ratio
between the estimate is at least mu we
are sure that q1 Q2 and Q3 all these
jobs are going to be shorter than q and
we want to put the shorter jobs
tow towards the top
of this beam
so the way to do it is actually to do
the way to do and this is very depending
on the proof is to do a cyclic shift so
q1 I'm going to put Q at the bottom
instead of Q3 Q3 is going to move to Q2
Q2 is going to move to q1 and Q by 1 is
going to be at the top specifically this
is the example I'm going to show it
again because it's a bit confusing Q is
going down instead of Q3 is going here
Q2 is going here and q1 is going here so
I'm going to do what's called C click
shift among only the jobs which are
certainly shorter than Q note this this
job is not necessarily shorter it's
actually might be shorter but we don't
know if it's a shorter or not shorter
and this does not uh
um does not participate in the um in the
C click shift C click shift process
so uh this is how we deal with jobs
which are released and then at the top
of the of the of the uh being we have
jobs which are supposedly shorter I mean
the like the jobs are sorted but not
really not precisely sorted they um it's
approximately sorted because if job is
really as a large estimate it will be in
the bottom and a small estimate it will
be in the top but it's not going to be a
complete sorting because we have this uh
error of new so this is how we
maintain the beam with the um with the
uh full jobs
and what about processing now I'm which
job are going to be processed the job
which is processed is going to be the
one at the top of the partial jobs again
job the person at every point of time
only one job is processed and this will
be at the job at the top of this uh of
this video and uh
um and and specifically in some sense
it's a it's a leave for because jobs are
going to move from the full jobs to the
uh sorry for memo uh from the um
from the full bin to the partial beam
and actually the in some sense it's a
leave for the job in the partial being
are processed in a lethal fashion
and
um there are also other possible choices
but uh which which works but we but this
lifo is the simplest now I only need to
describe how to transfer a job
from the full beam to the partial beam
so uh every time that the full being has
more jobs than the partial beam then uh
I'm just I'm going to move the Tojo
which is supposedly the shorter one it's
not necessarily the real shorter one but
approximately the shorter jobs I'm going
to move it from the full beam from the
top of the full beam to the top of the
partial wheel so in some sense these two
bins have exactly the same number of
jobs or alternatively the post the
partial beam has one more job because
once
once uh the uh full beam has already won
more jobs from the partial job then we
move a job from the fault of the partial
and if uh job is ends so uh this one
becoming shorter again we are going to
move the job from here to here
so this is the whole algorithm and
um and uh
yeah and I'm not going to describe the
proof but this is only a description of
the algorithm
a natural question would be why I'm
really going back why I'm really
maintaining here approximate sorting and
I'm not sorting it according to the
estimates this would be this would seem
more natural why I'm insisting of
keeping jobs with larger estimates above
jobs with smaller estimates and the
reason is that they unfortunately if we
sort the job completely
and the uh error is for example
Distortion is for this algorithm
completely fails so surprisingly we need
to maintain approximate sorting and not
real sorting
so uh this is this is not
um yeah this is not lack of
impossibility to prove this is really
required in the algorithm
so now I'm going to describe how the
algorithm how to change the algorithm to
the weighted case so again as I
mentioned this was the algorithm for the
unweighted case when we know the
Distortion now I'm going to switch to
the case of the weighted case with a
known distortion so here I'm actually
going to uh I'm I'm going to round the
weights of each job to a power of 2. so
please note that the weight of the job
the executive of weight of the job is
not really so important because if we
have only if we run the job the weight
of the job to the next power of two we
only lose a factor of two this is very
different than rounding the processing
time rounding the processing time is
impossible if we have a job of size one
and if we round it even to one plus
Epsilon or let's say we have jobs of
size 1 minus Epsilon and we round it to
job of size one
there are flow time the response time
can increase from linear to quadratic so
we are not allowed to touch the
processing time of the job and the
algorithm is very sensitive to the exact
processing time while it's now so it's
not really sensitive to the weight so
this is why we are allowed to uh around
the weight but not really
around the processing time so here what
we do is actually we have a pair of full
beam and a partial Beam for each weight
class so we have here weight class of
one so again the height is the height is
the weight so here the jobs evaluate one
here the jobs have way too and here the
the jobs eight weights have wait for and
for each class for each weight class we
have a pair of four jobs and partial
jobs and we behave as as expressly in
the unweighted case for each such pair
so the only difference is which job we
need to process because before we had to
process the job from the partial bin but
now we have multiple partial bin so uh
we just process the one with the tallest
tallest beam so in this case we're
talking about this A4
um so um so this is the algorithm and
again I'm going I'm not going to be to
talk about the analysis because it's a
technical and delicate I'm going I'm not
much time is left I'm not sure how long
I'm only going to very briefly talk
about the Distortion of Believix
algorithm so again I'm let me remind you
here I had to assume that I know the
Distortion or upper bound of distortion
in advance
the more complicated case is that we
don't know registration and events and
here we only know how to handle
um
um the unweighted case
um so I'm not sure do I have here only
two minutes so I have more time because
if I have two minutes there is no way to
describe the algorithm so the algorithm
is a bit
I'm just given
pictures we have estimate we put we
classify the jobs according to their
estimates and we have a nice type of job
this is a snapshot of the business
system you'll see you have five you have
seven minutes so five minutes seven
minutes okay sorry so let me if I have
seven minutes I'm I'm actually
um let me
yeah let me um
Steve let me say something about
something about the idea of the proof
and not and not necessarily about the
description of the algorithm is as
follows if we
um let's say that at any point of time
an algorithm is delta T pending jobs
while the optimum has Delta started
number of pending jobs
so if we are what's called local
competitive which means that we have
seen more tax at most factor of c times
number of jobs compared to the opt then
uh this would imply a c competitive
algorithm and the reason is that the
flow time is actually the integral over
time of the number of live jobs uh the
thing is that we actually uh also need
the other direction in order to prove I
see competitive algorithm we need to we
need to be also local competitive and
this is with some disclaimer which I'm
not going to describe so let me just
describe the algorithm very briefly I'm
looking at the jobs I'm dividing them
according to their uh processing time
according to their classes each job
according to the class uh is uh is
dispersing line between two to the I2 to
I plus one so here are the shorter jobs
and here are the longer and and I have
four jobs which are empty circles and
partial jobs which are full and polygon
polygons and there is difference between
the tights but I'm not going to have
time to describe the difference
and we are going to have at most one
partial job per class because partial
jobs are not competing with each other
in the same class but it might have
um many full job in a class and
um and the natural thing is that we want
to have a preference to Shorter jobs
jobs with shorter estimated time
um and at any point of time you are
going to process the job with the lowest
class which is partial so this is like a
snapshot of the of the jobs and here we
have uh some food jobs which are empty
some uh partial jobs which are uh which
are a full and we are not necessarily
going like naturally we want to prefer
the shorter job to process the soldier
jobs but are not necessarily going to do
it sometimes we are going to process
jobs which are closed in the next uh
class and not necessarily the one that
we expect it to be shorter
so
uh one natural algorithm is to run the
lowest closest lowest class first which
means ever preference to the jobs of the
shorter estimation this is a very
natural natural algorithm every time I
have preferenced the shorter one but the
problem with that is that I might be
left with tiny part of jobs over time
and I'm going not going to finish every
job so we need something there is
something else which is called a Special
Rule and I don't have time to describe
it and actually our algorithm it's
called zigzag it com sometimes it's used
the lowest class first sometimes it
seals uses the uh Special Rule and
sometimes change the job from uh um from
one option to the other and obviously I
don't have time to describe it so I'm
going to skip it
um yeah and of course also the proof and
conclusions and auto problems so
conclusions
um
again I was talking about minimizing the
total flow time total response time
for the unweighted case we have mule of
Mio competitive algorithm and almost
matching lower bound
for the weighted case we don't have a
distortion obligence we need to know an
upper bound on the on the error in
advance and we get uh appropriate bounds
so uh I'm switching to open problems and
we'll be finishing with the open
problems so uh okay this is as I said
the most interesting open program was to
obtain a distortion or believe its
algorithm for the weight case uh with
this we don't have any idea okay how to
do
uh another uh more minor problem is uh
closing the gap between the upper bound
on and the lower Bound for the
Distortion oblivious case okay there is
also difference between there is a gap
in the
um in the robust case but this is more
interesting but it's a minor difference
and the third problem is to deal with a
multiple machines here we have recently
a new paper which will appear in Isaac
and deal with multiple machines in some
sense multiple machines like it seems
that multiple machines is going to be
harder than the single machine but
surprisingly simpler because the
competitive ratio to begin with with
multiple machine is worse than a single
machine so we're shooting for a worse
result because the competitive rush to
begin with is Wars so actually multiple
machines since we need to shoot for a
worse result it's easier compared to a
single machine which seems a little
Paradox but uh but this is this is the
case
that's it thank you and I'm happy to
answer questions
hi this is uh Zee from CMU great because
I really enjoyed this talk
um I had a question about the Distortion
definition kind of being one even when
you have a sort of all the jobs
estimates are scaled
um and the question is basically uh do
you have any insight in sort of what
your algorithm ends up producing to in
that case and uh whether
and like does it simplify or anything
like that
so again I mean the fact that the if all
jobs are scaled it's a feature it's not
a bug because you are in in that case
even if your estimates are wrong but
there are all of them have the same
scale you you get a constant competitive
algorithm so even if your estimates are
a thousand times the real real size of
the job you still you still get one or
two competitive algorithm because it's
uniform overall jobs so it's a feature
it's not a bug in that sense it's a
feature of the algorithm you get a
better bound
and and and and and the reason for that
is that
um yeah I mean I wouldn't say that the
algorithm is uh behaves uh when you
scale the numbers the algorithm does not
behave exactly the same but it's uh but
see but the order remains in some sense
the same
I'm not sure if I reply to what you
precisely asked
Steve gives a thumbs up
oh my uh it was a great talk um I I had
one question about the Distortion um so
this came from the motivation of you
don't know what your job processing
times look like ahead of time so you
know Distortion gives you some like
leeway
um in um in your assumptions but how
might you like uh no Distortion ahead of
time like in order to either like a use
the right algorithm in the robust case
or B know how tight your algorithm is
like know like the bounds on it and what
happens if like maybe your your drops
are coming from some distribution are
there times they're coming from some
distribution where you know like maybe
it's not exactly bounded but like uh
it's like close to its expected value or
something
so again for oblivious distortional
beliefs algorithm you don't know you
don't need to know the Distortion in
advance the performance of the algorithm
depends on the actual Distortion but you
don't need to know the Distortion in
advance you just run the algorithm and
the performance depends on how how bad
was your estimates and during the Autumn
you really discover how how how precise
are your estimates because you run you
run the uh you run the uh the jobs so
um and you're right about the robust
case robust case you need to know view
in advance which is tricky and it's not
clear how to do it as I mentioned in the
beginning typically uh you assume that
you have either a prediction on that and
you look at historical uh uh historical
information about these jobs and you can
uh with maybe with high probability you
can get a good estimate and from time to
time your agro2 will fail if the
estimate is incorrect assuming you will
use the robust robust algorithm and not
a distortional believe this algorithm
so in the end of time let's take other
questions over email and let's thank our
speaker again
[Applause]
okay